Princess Charlotte looking adorable
arriving at her first day of school the
four year old kicked off her reception
year or pre kindergarten at Thomas's
Battersea in London on Thursday with mom
Kate Middleton dad Prince William and
big brother Prince George all fireside
it was really important for Kate to be
there because she actually had to miss
Prince George's first day at Thomas's
she was sick bed bound in the early
stages of her pregnancy with Prince
Louie and I was told by very close
friends of hers that she was heartbroken
to not be able to see Prince George off
for his first day of school so I think
it was a very special occasion
obviously today for it being Charlotte's
first day at school but the whole family
looked absolutely delighted
like most kiddos Charlotte seemed to
have a slight case of the first-day
jitters hiding behind her mum as cameras
snapped photos and needing a gentle
nudge when it came time to meet teacher
Helen Haslam I think probably she she
was a little apprehensive but she has a
reputation for being and pretty feisty
very confident Prince George may be the
eldest child but I think it's I think
it's Charlotte who calls the shots and
has everyone running rings around her
and if that handshake and pony tail flip
doesn't scream confidence we don't know
what does even her shire brother nailed
the greeting having come a long way
since his first day at Thomas's back in
2017 there hasn't been any special
treatment for George or Charlotte
peroneus one of the reasons that the
Cambridge's wanted to enroll them at
Thomas's but there's one major change
that like George Charlotte will have to
get used to Charlotte will be known as
Charlotte Cambridge so that will be her
name when she's called out on the
register but I suspect her friends will
call her what most of her friends called
her at Wilcox nursery school which is
Lottie and that's a name that her
parents call her the other nickname that
she had when she was at Wilcox nursery
where she was up until just before the
summer was the warrior princess and I'm
wondering if that might be a nickname
that will stick with her apparently she
earned that nickname because obviously
she is a princess but she's quite a
tomboy
you know she loves climbing trees and
she's very much an adventurer I think
she was quite known for her feisty
personality so we'll wait to see whether
that nickname sticks as for what little
body we'll be learning during her first
year she will take English should be
reading writing basic arithmetic re is
one of the subjects is taught and ballet
when the stand that Charlotte is
passionate about dance and she goes to
ballet school already so that's probably
something that she's really going to
enjoy but she'll be covering a broad
spectrum and for the Early Years
Foundation luckily she shall have her
big brother to help show her the ropes
George and Charlotte are great buddies
they're very very firm friends they're
incredibly close they're great play
mates so Charlotte will be familiar with
some of those friends which I think has
probably made her her first day at
school and probably the coming weeks
much easier
[Music]